thaïs vous voyez un petit peu ce qui se
passe dans le monde actuellement pas du
tout oui complètement ce que je le
constat que je fais c'est que la société
multiculturelle qu'on nous déloge parle
pas de ça vous voyez ce qui se passe un
petit peu actuellement dans le monde
avec toutes les difficultés qu'on a avec
cette crise sanitaire incroyable qu'il y
a dans le monde
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le
moment est-ce que vous pensez que votre
groupuscule aujourd'hui à sa place est
ce que vous pensez que c'est vraiment
une priorité
ce que vous faites actuellement vous
avez vu ce qui se passe dans le monde
vous avez pas peur vous avez 20 ans vous
avez pas peur pour vous plus tard vous
n'avez pas peur de ce qui se passe
actuellement
moi ce que je trouve que je trouve que
vous avez des priorités qui sont pas les
bonnes à votre robe
moi ce que je crains si dur et vous
c'est que la civilisation européenne
elle est aujourd'hui menacée de
disparaître par cette invasion
migratoire dans non non non là bas dit
la société européenne et la société le
monde est aujourd'hui menacée
disparaître parce qu'il ya un virus qui
en train d'émerger partout on sait pas
ce qui va se passer il ya des variants
on en a parlé ya deux années un instant
avec patrick peloux il ya des baryons
qui émergent dans tous les pays du monde
il ya une situation économique est
catastrophique dans le monde entier donc
je pense que les migrants ou les
étrangers ou l'immigration n'est pas
responsable de ce phénomène et de ce qui
se passe actuellement et je pense que le
fléau vous êtes sur le mauvais sujets
non mais là on parle de deux choses
différentes mais avant de parler de kovy
db oui mais bon non mais c'est pour ça
moi je sais a maintenant vous voyez ce
qui se passe si vous êtes dans votre
truc je parle tout part d'un problème
qui existait bien avant le caviste qui
existera bien après locaux vides étaient
également étiez si vous voulez le
problème du coc vide
il va être temporaire non non non le
secteur power merci ça fait un an qu'on
dit qu'il va être temporaire à vous dire
en attendant il est passé pour sa
paroisse et moi on a cette idée invasion
migratoire qui elle est urgente la
question de l'identité réelle via deux
fois plus de français qui naissent à
l'étranger que d'étrangers qui naissent
en france elle est où l'invasion
migratoire
mais à cette légèreté c'est la réalité
elle est allée chercher un autre chiffre
très simple une invasion migratoire
c'est quand vous avez un
c'est les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur de 2019 quatre cent mille
entrées en france c'est l'équivalent de
nice nice qu est la cinquième ville de
france
donc je vais vous donner un exemple très
simple si vous prenez allez un
quinquennat cinq ans vous multiplier ce
chiffre par cinq sa fait 2 millions
d'entrées en france 2000
on c'est l'équivalent de la population
de la plus jeune nation